(audience applauds)
All righty then,
it is time for Drew's News.
The good news sprinkles on your news cake
with that satisfying good news crunch. (clicks teeth)
(audience laughs)
(Ross chuckles)
Do sprinkles crunch?
They do, yeah.
I have some experience with them and they do, right.
They get in your teeth.
You know what I'm talking about? Yeah.
I think they're just so pretty, I never eat them.
Well with me at the desk is the best co-pilot in the world,
Rossy Ross Mathews.
Yeah thank you so much.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)
Now I want sprinkles.
Now you want sprinkles?
Now I do.
I'll get you some sprinkles.
Please don't get me sprinkles, please.
Look at my body.
I'm trying to keep it together,
don't get me anything with sprinkles on it.
I know.
Ugh, pendulum over here, mm-mm-mm-mm.
Well, we are starting with style news.
Now remember, we are losing our minds
over Netflix's new deal with Nancy Meyers,
to make a new movie. (mock hyperventilates)
Okay, so Metro reports
that the latest style icon is Diane Keaton,
in every Nancy Meyers movie ever.
Yes, understood.
And the trend
is officially called, "The coastal grandmother look".
(audience laughs)
All right.
Well, the style is cozy chic and very breathable.
For some inspo, check out Diane in "Something's Gotta Give".
Any day, all day, I'll watch that movie.
Oh yeah, okay.
I see coastal there.
Yes.
Well, I mean, there's an ocean
so if you don't see coastal, something's wrong with you.
Let's see Meryl Streep in "It's Complicated".
Oh yeah, uh-huh.
Uh-huh.
Giving her Santa Barbara best.
Yes.
We're talking linens,
neutrals, anything like that.
Good flow for sitting back and draining that bottle of wine.
And I also love a cream cable-knit turtleneck,
with a linen pant and a bottle of Pinot Grigio.
(audience laughs)
I am living my coastal grandmother fantasy
just about every single day.
We're all picking up what Nancy Myers is putting down.
Thank you so much.
Well, next up, we've got an insane story
from your hometown of Los Angeles, Drew.
Oh.
Yeah, listen to this.
NPR reports, a woman was standing
at one of those lottery ticket vending machines.
Oh, this is crazy.
She was deciding which scratcher ticket she was gonna buy,
when a stranger rudely bumped into her,
hitting her arm,
made her purchase a $30 ticket,
which she never would've picked if it were up to her.
And she was so irritated, she went back to her car,
she scratched it off and she won $10 million.
Can you believe this story?
(audience gasps and applauds)
10.
(audience applauds)
I didn't think things like this were possible.
Have you ever won anything,
on a lottery ticket, or...?
My life.
Your life?
Yeah, you won the lottery, didn't you?
Yeah.
I feel like I did.
Oh, that's cute.
(audience applauds)
That's cute.
Oh, okay.
With all it's ups and downs.
Yeah.
That's a way more poignant answer than mine.
One time I accidentally hit the Bet Max,
on a penny slot, in Palm Springs, it was $5 spin,
and I won a hundred dollars.
(audience cheers)
I did.
(squeals) In pennies?
On pennies.
No!
Yes.
It doesn't, I mean, I-
Is it still spitting out pennies as we speak?
'Cause a hundred dollars in pennies, I...
That's how the pilgrims did slot machines.
Now they just give you a little piece of paper
that says a hundred dollars.
No, no, no!
Yes.
Yeah, you don't get coins anymore.
No coins, no.
No.
When was the last time you went to a casino?
1970 what?
(audience laughs)
Come on.
I'm always on the Black Jack table.
Oh.
And I like to split fives and do everything wrong
and make the whole table mad at me,
and the dealer's furious
and the people who are riding are just mad at me.
But I tend to do okay.
So it pays off, that risky behavior pays off for you.
(bright theme music)